we about to go up bro
bootlegate podcast special guests in
here one of the hottest in the city
Zoro Sam is here what is the deal
welcome man I appreciate it man of
course you've been doing your thing man
I've been trying but yeah a day at a
time which I guess it's starting to pay
off congratulations on uh I see you
posting your numbers all the time and
getting all these huge playlists
Replacements and
what do you would you say because I do
feel like that is one of the biggest
uphill battles it feels like for La
artists is to kind of get
the music industry is east coast bias a
lot of the people who curate these
playlists are East Coast bias like what
do you think is kind of the secret to
like your success so far
um promote your music non-stop not just
a few times a week or
for a month and then go on to the next
song I think I promoted the song long
enough to the point that it was able to
reach over there for somebody to even
put it on their platform because if I
would just posted this [__] a few times
when it came out left alone it wouldn't
touch no plan platforms or playlists
especially not organically right you
know so I think a lot of artists coming
up feel like if the song don't take off
in the first month
two months top that it's a it's a dud
but that's when they really be having it
[__] up if you're an independent
artist you're going to probably at least
take you a year or two to make one
single move if you know and that's the
difference between the major and do it
yourself yeah no it's crazy because most
people give up on hit records
before they become hits I see it all the
time you'll hear a record back yo this
is a [__] hit record but because it
did not take off in the first 30 days of
it being released new song next week
yeah like uh there's a dude from the Bay
who you probably heard of uh stunner man
who had the big step in record he he
he's another pushing that record every
[__] day he's a prime example what
can happen you see he got to the 49ers
yeah into Golden State Warriors so
that might be a song he never have to
work again off of you know if you do if
you make it with if you follow his
protocol like how some artist is doing
him and the Russell and people like that
you're gonna win bro do you pay
attention to a guy like Russell who I
feel like has kind of
you know in my opinion helped kind of
guide a whole new generation of like
what it means to be independent I [__] a
little Russell heavy the Russell is the
Bay Area Nipsey hustle with um
businessing and marketing and do it
yourself so he's he's taking what nip
she did and doing it in his working for
him and he's showing you that what
Nipsey was saying he's proven to you
guys the shit's real yeah so I [__] with
Russell heavy and that's a um that's
really like a method that I'm going off
of you know
and [__] every day we just we just keep
on pushing bro that's what it's all
about I just really feel people be
giving up too fast what part of L.A are
you from I'm from South Central I'm from
I'm I'm actually off the east side of
South Central okay like Firestone
District that's what's up
um do you feel like
LA because I always say this like it
seems like nowadays more than maybe like
10 years ago or even like five or six
years ago a lot of the new generation of
La artists
um I wouldn't say put politics aside but
I feel like a lot more people are
working with each other a lot more
people are more open to like supporting
each other you know what I mean I mean
obviously there are examples of that not
being the case but do you feel like
there's more of a unified front amongst
the younger guys in LA right now
um it's getting better uh I said like
this is probably a big reason is a lot
of the
you know a lot of them guys is either
dead or in jail right now so you know we
really got generations of people that's
not really like that so the politics
don't matter as much to them and then
you have people like me that just have
been around and [__] that the politics
is [__] [__] right you know to a
certain extent
so I think in a way it's getting better
but it's all carried off of how you
carry yourself as a man first because
you can have the people that's talking
crazy that crazy things happen to or you
can have people like how nip came in the
game let you know where you're from
stand on ten toes at the same time as
respectful we'll take the peace but we
accept the war too but we rather take
the piece okay we're trying to get this
back so I just really think it's all all
of uh the mentality of how
the person is and how the rapper is how
did you get the Osama in your name
because uh obviously a legendary
terrorist uh right right he said Michael
Jordan a terrorism but you see in the
crazy thing about it
Michael Jordan the third I see the
greatest thing about it is the name
Osama means lion-like yeah I mean listen
uh right so I felt right I mean barack's
name is Barack wait no Hussein Obama no
I'm tripping see that was [__] it was
insane Hussein was in the middle
another some might argue legendary
terrorists
you're a legend Barack Hussein Obama's a
legend
Ary Terence is crazy but but honestly
that is crazy like like there like I
like that is crazy but like you know I
mean it's a great rap name it's a great
name but like what what made you uh you
know stick with that uh [__] was it like
man you [__] blowing up these beats
bro every time you rap this is great not
not actually uh in a way yeah I guess if
you put it like that but I just like I
went for the the definition of you know
lying like I feel like that's how I
stand but you know you got other people
using the same name for the legendary
Terrors you talk the guy from Chicago
right yeah wait yeah yeah he's hard too
but he's fired nice kid too and you go
he'd go up but you know a lot of people
is from the streets so they look at
Osama as a legendary terrorist right but
the definition of the name is Limelight
he gave a bad rap to the name he yeah
yeah it's nothing yeah it's like it's
like no one ever is gonna name their kid
Adolf anymore hey you want to know
what's crazy look I tried to make a
player in NBA 2k right and put Osama and
they told me that name was not allowed
to be that's some [__] because what
if that's your real name hey that's what
I was on I'm like you're some Muslim
person out there
from Osama for
Cemetery they were they would watch go
home and try to do that [__] just play
with the girl but like use another name
right it can't use that I'm like that's
crazy how long have you been like
rapping like and like taking it serious
where you were like all in on this [__]
2018 like December 2018 when I figured
out what the [__] this show kid was and
got off of SoundCloud yeah once I
figured that and I made a song called
Gang [__] and Iggy easty featuring my
boy to pre-grams he's a hard rapper out
of Long Beach you gotta get up with him
for sure but man we did this song years
ago and then still streaming right now
like since when it started and uh after
I seen you know how to get my music on
the platforms and people was actually
[__] with it I was orgasm right there
yeah cause like that's I feel like it's
crazy like distro kid and like tune core
for a long time people were like it was
like the hardest thing to figure out
well how do I get my [__] on iTunes man
I was
my head interested can figure out how
the [__] to do it and then I stumbled
across it at first I stumbled across the
[__] called CD Baby yeah CD Baby yep I
just couldn't afford I was I was down
bad I couldn't even afford to twenty
dollars so my brother had bought me a
description for this show kid for the 20
and I just pick I just you know any many
money just pick one but now I'm used to
this show so I just [__] additional
distro kid is great because you can pay
your producers right you can give
everybody this give them their splits
your manager everybody and then it's
like
from there you know what I'm saying sign
up for your own account right to get
your money because other than that you
know but yeah you can even put the you
can even get video creators Credit Now
on your own digital kid you can get
every they got a whole for anybody that
can do anything you could give them
credit and then it shows up on your
Spotify and places I'm assuming that
there has been a lot of discussions
about maybe you signing somewhere or
going to like maybe a bigger
distribution situation like what uh for
you
how important is it to keep your
Independence as long as possible or are
you even would you even consider doing
the major thing everything different for
everybody and I'm gonna say it like this
for me personally if the paperwork right
we can talk about it right that's the
point I don't care if it's a Indie you
know or major you know or halfway Indy
you know if the paperwork right and you
can manage off of that then it's it's
negotiable but I'm not I'm not all
against um signing with a major I'm just
all against the crazy ass deals that
people take without giving the paper to
a lawyer right so you know that kind of
leave a solitation a lot of people mouth
but when you start learning your
business you put that [__] to the side
in this business so I do feel like
labels need to start if an artist does
not have a lawyer I feel like it is
malpractice for them to allow an artist
to sign with them I mean I feel like
they low-key need to be like yo here's
twenty five hundred dollars go get a
lawyer for you to hire your own lawyer
right we're not going to hire the lawyer
for you because they work for us but but
that's like that's like saying that's
like the police officer telling you
after you get caught doors for [__]
because a lot of these labels they do
get people in like shitty predatory
deals at the same time like people sign
them that that's why you can't be mad at
what you sign so you signed it if you
signed it just for the money then you
you just got the money yeah and then now
don't get mad when the money goes yeah
you signed it but if you you know
you do some stupid [__] and and and you
know
I didn't see some crazy situations with
people you know right so it's just like
no I mean we hear about it all the time
people complaining like you'll hear the
biggest rappers with platinum records be
like I haven't seen any money off my ass
because they'd be signing these crazy
deals and they take the front in advance
with this smile on their face
and they don't recoup Market budget
that's what all that [__] costs money
and it's Gotta and then once you start
doing the math and you're like okay 3
900 for every million streams times
it's like okay you probably didn't even
recoup and you and you might have went
platinum you you didn't recoup you
weren't Platinum it's time to drop
another album they're gonna give you
another Budget on top of that it's like
every time you need more money you got
to drop a project so you probably signed
for a meal each project are you down to
the four project and you ain't recoup
from the first one but they keep giving
you a ticket bro you ain't you stuck and
then you're making albums for paydays
and not for like the artistic like
integrity that's how shitty albums
happened with a lot of these I mean but
it depends on what kind of person you
want to be you might want to be you
might want to be you might want to be an
artist or you might want to be exact
right is you know sometimes the artist
you know paying somebody 50 000 a year
every time you get ready to drop is
probably better than what they came up
from they probably came up from Food
Stamps and EBT so they probably still
winning and for some I always say this
too for some artists the take the
advance
because you're you're you caught a
little shitty tick tock song Wave take
that Advance because it's probably as
good as it's gonna get and do something
with it do something with it though for
sure see but that's where that's what
people [__] up you can take it but
Michael get an accounting some they give
you a little change go go figure out
where you can
you know move the [__] around that oh
[__] go back to doing what you know how
to make it make it happen right you feel
me do whatever you got to do but
don't get mad with everything gone and
start blaming the label for something
you agree with that's what part I don't
be like it'd be crazy hey we got to
interrupt the interview man hey shout
out to my bookie man make sure you go to
mybookie.ag NFL season it's over but it
might book you the opportunities to win
they're not over baby they don't stop
ever all right whether you want to make
some extra or just make the games more
exciting my book is going to give you
the most for your money with their
deposit bonuses now listen if you sign
up right now go to mybookie.ag use that
promo code bootleg you're gonna get a
welcome bonus up to a thousand dollars
and on top of that March Madness is on
the way ladies and gentlemen that's
right that college basketball tournament
is coming they're going to give you a
free hundred and fifty thousand dollar
March Madness bracket contest entry
imagine if you win 150 Grand you have to
put no money up crazy you gotta go to
mybookie.ag sign up with that promo code
bootleg right now thousand dollar
deposit bonus if you put a thousand and
they're gonna give you another thousand
all right and of course or so much to
bet on with my book you could do NCAA
NBA NHL UFC boxing what Jay is Jake Paul
gonna win I don't know but you could you
could put some money on Jake Paul I
would all right of course they also got
their weekly online Blackjack
tournaments so much roulette I mean
slots so much with so many Brands to
choose from trust my bookie I've been
rocking with them for over 10 years God
damn it and they're so easy to get your
money out of so easy to make money with
they got the best like simplest platform
to use the best props man trust me bet
anything anytime anywhere
with my bookie mybookie.ag promo code
bootleg sign up also shout out to our
family at hardean Jardine Las Vegas Yes
you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hard Dean man that's the family man go
if you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas uh for people who
aren't from Los Angeles if they're
visiting Town let's say for Rolling loud
this weekend
which is in Watts
Englewood not watching East Side website
it's the same [__] uh what is the safest
hat to wear
Dodger hat I know head always says the
black and white Dodger hat Dodger hat oh
you are you about yeah you could wear it
if you want to or the one I got I mean
see not only wearing this in the valley
see Luke I don't wear it though but you
know off of ballet but you know if you
just a law abiding a citizen
hey you just like you know
you're sure yeah there's certain hats
you you know like this is how this side
gonna [__] can see this hat from down
the block right like it just I don't
know something about it I was wearing a
um
a Texas Rangers hat oh yeah you they
that's that's the equivalent to this
right to listen so I was at uh Barry's
Pizza at like 2 30 in the morning
and I get hit up by big you
and uh he's like you know I have a
really good relationship with with big
you like I've known for a long time
um and he texts me he's like family we
gotta meet I need a face to face and
it's 2 30 in the morning and I'm with
Brian Sampson who hopefully you'll never
have to meet in your life I just just
because of that man that sound that
sketchy well we got to get to that one
it's a round Filipino
um so I'm like yo what's up you you know
it's like random to get a text for big
you at the middle of the night you know
what I mean and like sketchy he's like I
need a face to face we family we got to
talk and I'm like what's up bro he's
like issues
um and I'm like well he's like pull up
on me right now um I sound like somebody
getting the DP so this is when I I lied
and I was like man I'm all the way in
Valencia right now
what about tomorrow
and he's like if you're all the way in
Valencia why you got that hat on
and I'm like
who's over just started dying laughing
it's like bro and I ain't gonna lie my
bad bro
that's like the first thing you notice
about a dude when you see a dude got a
hat on what kind of hat is it yeah
that's like from that's like La culture
for sure so I would say if it's not a
basketball team
or La hat what about the Arizona
Diamondbacks that's the d-hat right
don't wear that hat I mean you can't
it's about the a what about the a oh no
for sure don't wear that hat okay so
just the Diamondbacks are out because
everyone's always telling you the
Diamondbacks are kind of safe no that's
what I'm saying it's kind of safe
because it's not the Detroit hat okay so
you know but it's still the D you might
you might be from a certain place and
just want to wear the DIY because it go
you know you get the dominant back
instead of the Detroit it's not about
the Hat it's about the last letter the
letter the letter it might be a it might
be an ny hat that's not a Yankee hat and
it just got NY on it it's the NY what
you got that NY info wow it's that type
of situation in L.A so it's black black
and white L.A hat you could do the blue
and white too you could do any nah stay
away from the
when you have a red La hat on it look
kind of sketchy yeah like you a domino
for sure
the blue La hat I've heard is like
that's like the official South Side
that's like the inside yeah yeah that's
the essay I have for sure I mean if you
black and you wear it you're good to go
okay all right if you like Caucasian
that's good too so let's say I'm
Caucasian
but you could you could you could
low-key pass for Hispanic bro I listen
you can pass for Hispanic definitely
like if you're in a wrong area where
like I get off wrong
they gonna get on you let's say I got to
get off the 110 right I gotta get gas oh
someone comes up to me and they're like
yo where you from nowhere what do I say
nowhere at all or tell them where you're
actually from someone told me I need to
just start acting like super like Angry
like I'm fighting with my girl get your
ass knock man I'm dealing with this
[__] I don't even know where I'm at I
just call my [__] cheating on my mama
[__] gonna hit you so hard because you
you might you might start alone you
might eat my hold on what's up with this
[__] no but don't ever do that don't I
ain't gonna lie someone said just start
acting like you're fighting with your
girl and you're lost look I see I seen
this by I've seen this by experience it
might be that I've seen it it happened a
lot man you know you might be somewhere
Yo Hood or whatever the case may be
somebody might bang on somebody that
don't be from nowhere but then he
started trying to put his foot down as a
man like bro I just said now you're
getting knocked out right now I mean now
you're talking to me crazy in my hood
now I gotta get on you that's how people
think it's [__] up when you're
thinking but in in situations with gang
members just tell them you're not from
nowhere and if that that goal where you
can see you can see the body language do
what you got to do to get about the
situation I had a situation where he was
there we were in uh Vallejo which is the
crest in Vallejo which is like a a very
uh legendary area right I was just out
there and uh we were supposed to be
shooting with a rapper from Vallejo not
La Russell
um and I guess like right before we got
there
somebody who knew this rapper got into
like a situation like a violent
situation with somebody and they knew
that that guy was going to be there to
shoot something so we're there with our
cameras and [__] about to shoot a piece
of content I don't know what's about the
transfer this motherfucker's got his
drone in the air in front of King's
Market was a King's Market yeah any
anywhere that's named King is probably
the middle of the ghetto so listen so I
know I mean I already know where I'm at
you know so I know so these guys come up
and they're like hey you guys with
so-and-so and I was like I was like hey
man no so these guys got chains on that
like like record label chain I don't
know they have some [__] that I'm like
okay these guys might be artists
so I'm like I just said hey what's good
bro I introduced myself
I'm like yeah man we just shooting some
content you know with so and so I didn't
say the guy's name you just confirmed
somebody gonna be here no no no no I
realized we needed to leave immediately
but I'm like yo what's up I'm you know I
introduced myself and I'm like hey you
know I do radio I got a podcast hey
y'all do music hey let me follow y'all
you know so I'm like
we're we're following each other back
you know and I'm like man I'm gonna tap
in you know I'm never gonna tell I'm
like I'm like hey I'm like hey man my
boy we gotta go pick up the other
cameraman at the hotel on the other side
of the freeway we'll be right back but
like I'ma tap in we'll be right back
meanwhile I tell our boy land the
[__] drone cause we gotta get the
[__] out of here that is crazy this is
yeah
yeah and so like when people go do
content in the hood not saying that
y'all not comfortable or good where
y'all go is how did that feel like when
y'all I know y'all gotta go to the slums
I'm from the slums and when
[__] be like hey bro we over
here right cause I know I'm like you
know so like so I've been like like
doing this show called tapped in with
Empire for a while where we'll go to
like areas I know yeah and um I've never
really felt like that was the only time
where I was like
okay we should probably get about it but
you said you was in Valero yeah and I
and I went back to Vallejo we went back
to the same time I was at the gas
station Valero great gas station
shout out to Valero
3.99 at the gallon is good no but yeah
it's definitely uh you know I think I
think if you
are not from somewhere as long as you're
respectful and you're not acting like a
dick that's why I said Jews who don't
try to go back and forth with the gang
members just [__] you know be
respectful don't be a weirdo and uh by
the way weirdo another bad La word oh
yeah that's equivalent to Holly you know
like New York [__] be like suck my
dick yo well I'm calling a [__] a
weirdo you're being a weirdo hey that's
crazy because
that's crazy because weirdo serious
that's that's like you you could
probably get away with calling somebody
a [__] before you say word on LA or
South Central I would like to point out
I mean not doing that I say about you
I'm saying you I'm saying like if you're
saying my [__] knife with the ER but
you feel me when you get them but people
like bro you was a weirdo weird ass
[__] oh yeah say less oh yeah you might
as well go ahead and start wrapping it
up so are you saying that if I say suck
my dick and weirdo it's similar levels
of disrespect I lied to you suck my
dicks crazy it is crazy that's crazy
like like you know [__] from New York
they'd be like they say that [__] freely
that's like suck my dick son that's like
how you be playing with your friend
you're like shut up [__] you know like
that's crazy bro like to suck my dick is
like whoa so if you want to get into a
serious situation my dick is crazier you
run to suck my dick you weirdo I mean if
I go to New York and call a [__] a
weirdo they probably be like
so what like but if a [__] tell me hey
suck my dick you weird ass [__] now you
got a double double you got something
gotta happen that's [__] that's
Anthony Davis healthy right now no yeah
no New York win on the [__] talking they
win for sure they they talk crazy yeah
New York they talk crazy as [__]
definitely East Coast guys I think in
general that they have to deal with more
people on a daily basis now they just be
yeah they'd be mad of course they're on
subways and what I mean have you been in
New York no but all the videos on
Instagram
hey when you go to New York New York
though no when you go to New York you'll
understand why everybody from New York
is the way they are I mean I could kind
of see it because your entire day you're
around strangers every day no matter
what but the New York [__] have no
filter okay they can't not even the
females don't even the females sound
like the [__] yeah I don't suck my
dick yo I'll be like damn dude they wow
they wow son yeah they're wild hey shout
out to Pete Davidson just back to New
York they music be going up though y'all
keep doing your thing y'all wild though
who would you consider to be your
biggest influences like as a as in terms
of rapping
um
imma go
nip I'm gonna always have to put both
first he got me to where I'm at as far
as business-wise and made me open my
eyes then we're gonna go Dre Snoop Cube
Suga Free DJ Quick empty ain't
we gonna go
um Easy E gotta go easy we're gonna go
with the whole dog pound in the
Eastsiders we're gonna go with
um
I always Lil Boosie and Webby Savage
Life yeah for sure all all the
Collectibles uh Mind of a Maniac oh I
love my name yo the video I might have a
maniac where he had his eyelids yeah man
my little cousin I used to hate that
[__] I can't do that [__] I used to
people that do that weirdos weirdos but
um
yeah so but I ain't gonna lie probably
out of all that for me just naming West
Coast
I'm gonna have to go with boozy and
Webby because I used to [__] with them
more than a lot of West Coast artists in
2010 at that area when Boosie came out
with the mining the maniac and uh you
know him and Lil Wayne better believe it
and lower fat and um you know
you know that would that was with all
those questionable necklaces on the BET
Awards
I started looking at like back then I
like them big ass necklaces
right crazy man lap diamonds
hey hey as long as they pass on the
little tester it's good huh I agree I
mean who gives them for like yeah yo you
didn't spend 100 000 on this yeah
because I bought a house with that money
they still look good I'll [__] your
[__] it's still a diamond I'll [__] her
in the labs listen
[Laughter]
it's the same material and when the sun
hit it's going
you know what you say you say yeah my
diamond came from a lab yours came on
the sweat of a 12 year old African boy
with one arm
these diamond mines are [__]
my diamonds eco-friendly need a diamond
yeah that's crazy you want your blood
diamonds I'll take my lab created
diamonds but like who who really just be
up on somebody to the point that you be
like I really don't care about material
extinct so you don't really see me with
jewelry but I got it if I want to buy it
I could bust down my whole [__] right
but it's just but you're not you're not
you know I've been there done that see
my thing is
I'm at the point now where I'm getting
it through the music right because I
didn't grow up raised in the streets
section they all that I didn't got it I
didn't see the most money off the
streets and lost the most money in the
streets so now I know I didn't lost it
twice the third time you would never
lose it again so I'm on my third chance
right now I know how to move my money
and save it and put it right here you
know I got I got kids that I gotta if
anything you know they gotta make I
gotta make sure something good with them
they might have to need a medical bill
that's a hundred thousand dollars right
and if you gotta have that [__] ready or
else they ain't gonna get done to them
that's how the world works so I just got
different priorities but don't get it
wrong
when a [__] get like a meal ticket plus
I'm gonna bust down again but right now
I feel like most people wear jewelry for
other people
[__] wear a dream for [__] right
if right now [__] we follow a trend of
[__] saying ain't nobody wearing
jewelry no more that [__] bogus
everybody will stop wearing jewelry
right but if the [__] is liking this is
gonna go bust they [__] right down just
a [__] [__] that [__] probably
broke as hell right so
I don't know uh I can't call it hey we
got to stop the interview to tell you
about our good Folks at Blue chew baby
that's right A lot of people keep asking
me does Bluetooth work [__] yeah it does
and if you don't believe me they'll give
you a whole month for free right now if
you go to bluetooth.com and use that
promo code bootleg that's bootry.com
promo code bootleg you get a month of
blue chew for free delivered to your
[__] house all you do is pay five
dollars in shipping what is blue tree
you ask well let me tell you it has the
same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable tablet but it is
discreetly delivered right to your
doorstep no awkward doctor's visits
imagine going and telling uh an old guy
about your dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know but
you could do it all online bluetooth.com
you don't have to go to the doctor's
appointment in person no more no they're
gonna send it straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know
that you came and it came all right so
what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just drop their new mint chewable which
is the same exact active ingredient as
Levitra so many options for you at
Bluetooth to make sure your dick is
right going into the springtime baby
look spring break's coming uh are you
gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner going to be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month's supply for
free and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
so much going on at Odd Socks uh so many
dope licenses man shout out to uh they
got Cheetos they got Jaws [__] Oreos
Cheech and Chong Naruto WWE by the way
wrestlemania's coming I can't wait to
see what dope WrestleMania socks they do
this year because last year they knocked
it out the park at odd Sox look the most
comfortable socks in the world they got
The Odd Socks Basics that you need on
your feet uh all you gotta do is go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg at checkout you'll
save 20 off your total order underwear
socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola draws Coca-Cola socks so much
always going on in Odd Socks I'm gonna
always say my favorites are the WWE in
the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you will
save 20 off at checkout shout out to
them most comfortable socks in the world
crazy comfortable underwear my goodness
if you ain't got Odd Socks on your feet
and ass what are you doing out in these
streets all right go to
hotsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview what do you got coming uh in
terms of uh down the pipeline I knew
you've been dropping a lot what
music-wise what do you got coming up uh
I'm making a lot of music right now just
just making music but however we do got
underrated volume two that's gonna be
the name of the project that's coming up
and we also got the remix I can't say
the name
but we got some
La guys
I can't say the name but where are they
from
they from the world you're gonna see I
wanted to be a surprise when people be
like damn how you do that you feel me so
from the world they're from the world
they they you know so but it's like damn
how many people
as of now well actually for the remix I
got a lot of versions of it but the one
that we bought the you're gonna have
multiple remixes yeah I want to do like
the welcome to Atlanta thing so you're
gonna have Atlanta guys I have somebody
from Florida on it someone from Florida
yeah
I got somebody from Florida I got
um I could say money signed suede
because I didn't already put that on
Instagram last year shout out to suede
is he still uh in jail yeah free bro
freehand yeah nice kid yeah a good guy a
real stand-up guy that's my [__] yeah I
think he's doing a good job too because
I do feel like like uh the new
generation is breaking the [__]
parents say like Latino rappers I feel
like this new like wave like Bravo him
are like free Bravo too bringing the two
you know two sides of La together that's
not the only one though you got you got
Doughboy from the Inland Empire there's
a bunch of people I'm just saying like I
feel like the new wave of Latin rappers
are like it's dope to see like everyone
working together you know you yeah it is
and it's even Doper to see the black and
the Browns [__] with each other with
the with the sound because [__] we all
come from the same [__] place you
your rent is the same as my rent bro we
both from section eight you figure it
out like you know like so
you like me I'm like you it ain't no
difference between the brown and the
black community at all it's just what
the picture is painted in the fake ass
division line that shouldn't even really
be there I wasn't even hip to all of
that before moving here it's only in La
it's a Malay [__] it's it's not it's not
it's not even and it's game politics
right it's it's something that's higher
up about higher up [__] that has nothing
to do with nothing but for soldiers
that's going to listen to yeah cause
like in AZ like wear like a they they
love each other yeah it's just some La
politics La politics is different the
Hispanics the Spanish people Hispanics
like you know like blasphemy for blacks
it's just it's just different but it
gets light gets shined on when it's the
two different races going to war with
each other but if you just look at the
[__] graphics on what really happens
in La Hispanics before Hispanics blacks
beats with blacks everybody beef with
everybody and everybody get along with
everybody but when it's something that
can be marketed as negative and racial
it's always going to make the front pay
yeah that's the [__] that pushes uh
views right so you know
what's your top five La hip-hop albums
of all time
oh section 80.
a good kid Mad City we gotta go uh smell
my finger sugar-free oh uh we gotta go
with um what a name of an album uh Imma
have to go with uh what's the name of
the [__] album
Rhythm and gangster Snoop Dogg
really that's a great that's a that's a
very random Snoop album but a great one
that ups and downs was my favorite song
in the song that he made from Tookie
Williams him Nate Dogg and 213 Warren G
yeah that's one of my favorite I was
really deep in the streets at that time
so anything with a Blue Rag I was I was
sticking to it because Luke was my my
guy so um and we're gonna go with um
why we thugs Ice Cube
was that the name of the no the app what
was the name
no [__] I had it I know what you're
talking about I forgot the name of the
album by the way you have some random
that's a random Ice Cube album right
because I usually like music that
everybody I like to pick the albums that
everybody don't really well also that's
probably the albums that like were
coming up like that came out while you
were coming up I mean no I could have
said the old album was easy but
yeah right that so I could have set the
old album easy but
I feel like I feel like that's a
rejection that's the [__] that people
expect you to say you know but I'm a
real fan of their music so those are the
you're probably right those is when when
they was dropping at that time those was
the ones that I stick to so what's that
number four and we're gonna go with
Victory lap the [__] that should have
been number one a matter of fact his
whole catalog bro favorite song by nip
is paid my dudes bro that [__] got me
through a lot all right
what's the best album out of these five
you got to pick one
Victory lap good kid Mad City
doggy style
The Chronic and The Chronic 2001. credit
2001. okay I gotta say it Silas is sick
but Salas it's doggy style right okay
okay I know hey hey why we don't put get
rich or die trying in there because I'm
picking translation I just said all L.A
albums hey 50 you know you from New York
but [__] get rich or die trying that's
what else cause we love you my [__]
definitely not West Coast all the Autumn
beasts on there is West Coast type beats
that [__] is West Coast all right you're
right not all of them but that [__] he
broke off the West Coast he I mean
listen we go we go we go keep We Gonna
Keep 50 Cent who can we trade who can we
who could who can we trade who would you
trade you gotta give me a list give me a
list
huh
he's not about to make me just start
saying that give me a list and I'm gonna
pick off of your multiple choice all
right I'm gonna have 10 rappers okay you
gotta trade one of them for 50. all
right all right
50 one of my favorite rappers I really
don't give a [__] I'm just gonna start
naming off West coast rappers off the
top of my head oh don't say nothing new
okay off the top of my head if it's any
new rappers bro don't take it serious
because uh on the top of my head
all right girl
DJ Quick
YG
Dre
um
Mac 10
um ice cube hmm
sugar-free hmm he ain't going nowhere we
already know that the game
um Schoolboy Q
that's that's your list who's who's
trading for 50.
it's gonna be out of YG and Schoolboy Q
make your choice
school boy Q for 50 for 500 please hey
Schoolboy Q I love your music bro it's
nothing personal
it's nothing personal
I'm gonna trade I'ma trade you for 50
and I'm gonna put 50 at the top of the
list of everybody though so it's like
it's nothing personal I like I [__] with
50 Cent uh so uh remix coming soon how
soon is the remix coming I'll probably
say April Florida is on the remix
probably not the first one I'm gonna
drop
um because I'll tell you the first one I
just wanted to be such a surprise what
city in Florida
I'll tell you who said Hendrix oh Sadie
Hendrix yeah he's a sweet guy That's my
boy he's from Jacksonville right yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure I did a show for
him at the Roxy I opened up for him yeah
yeah said he's dope yeah yeah so that
that's one of the persons that's on the
remix I I don't know I've said that
already a couple times so
yes money side suede instead Teddy and
we got some
Zeke we on bro
well listen man I appreciate you pulling
up I'm looking forward to everything you
got in the works man you killing it
you're moving it the right way with the
right energy bro keep that [__] up and
uh we're gonna do a freestyle so you
guys can watch a separate YouTube video
this guy rapping
rapping they really they yeah they gonna
watch me rap let's go let's bootle cat
podcast